[Music]
Mohammed Ali spent years training to
become the greatest boxer the world had
ever seen but only moments to create the
shortest poem Ali captivated Harvard's
graduating class in 1975 with his
message of unity and friendship when he
finished the audience wanted more they
wanted a poem Ali delivered what is
considered the shortest poem ever me.we
or is it me we no one's really sure
regardless if these two words are a poem
then what exactly makes a poem a poem
poets themselves have struggled with
this question often using metaphors to
approximate a definition is a poem a
little machine a firework an echo a
dream
poetry generally has certain
recognizable characteristics one poems
emphasize languages musical qualities
this can be achieved through rhyme
rhythm and meter from the sonnets of
Shakespeare to the ODEs of Confucius to
the sanskrit vedas two poems use
condensed language like literature with
all the water wrung out of it three
poems often feature intense feelings
from roomies spiritual poetry to Pablo
Neruda's ode to an onion poetry like art
itself has a way of challenging simple
definitions while the rhythmic patterns
of the earliest poems were a way to
remember stories even before the advent
of writing a poem doesn't need to be
lyrical Reiner dulls Apfel and you can
gum ringers Silencio toe the line
between visual art and poetry meanwhile
EE Cummings wrote poems whose shapes
were as important as the words
themselves in this case amplifying the
sad loneliness of a single leaf falling
through space
if the visual nature of poetry faded
into the background perhaps we'd be left
with music and that's an area that
people love to debate our songs poems
many don't regard songwriters as poets
in a literary sense but lyrics from
artists like Paul Simon Bob Dylan and
Tupac Shakur often hold up even without
the music in rap poetic elements like
rhyme rhythm and imagery are inseparable
from the form take this lyric from the
notorious b.i.g
I can hear sweat trickling down your
cheek your heartbeats sound like
Sasquatch feet
thundering shaking the concrete so far
all the examples we've seen have had
line breaks we can even imagine the two
words of Ali's poem organizing in the
air me.we poetry has a shape that we can
usually recognize it's line breaks help
readers navigate the rhythms of a poem
but what if those line breaks
disappeared would it lose its essence as
a poem maybe not enter the prose poem
prose poems use vivid images and
wordplay but are formatted like
paragraphs when we look at poetry less
as a form and more as a concept we can
see the poetic all around us spiritual
hymns the speeches of orators like
Martin Luther King jr. JFK and Winston
Churchill and surprising places like
social media in 2010 journalist Joanna
Smith tweeted updates from the
earthquake in Haiti was in B room
getting dressed when heard my name
tremor ran outside through sliding door
all still now safe roosters crowing
Smith uses language in a way that is
powerful
direct and filled with vivid images
compared her language to a haiku the
ancient Japanese poetic form that
emphasizes bursts of brief intensity
with just three lines of five seven and
five syllables
the waters of poetry run wide and deep
poetry has evolved over time and perhaps
now more than ever the line between
poetry prose song and visual art has
blurred however one thing has not
changed the word poetry actually began
in a verb form coming from the ancient
Greek placeis which means to create
poets like craftsmen still work with the
raw materials of the world to forge new
understandings and comment on what it is
to be human in a way only humans can
Dartmouth researchers tested this idea
by asking robots to pen poetry a panel
of judges sorted through stacks of
sonnets to see if they could distinguish
those made by man and machine you may be
happy to know that while scientists have
successfully used artificial
intelligence in manufacturing medicine
and even journalism poetry is a
different story the robots were caught
red-handed 100% of the time
[Music]